hey everyone this is shruti from simply
learn
welcome to this video tutorial on cssp
training
in this training we will be focusing on
the world renowned certification
certified information systems security
professional
more often called cisp for all the cssp
aspirants out there
this video will brief you with cisp here
we will learn the importance of having a
cssp certification
what exactly cisp is all about cssp exam
requirements
and the various domains in cisp we will
also have an overview of the cssp exam
along with a few sample questions
for this training with me i have our
experienced cyber security specialist
bipin and together we will take you
through the various topics in cssb
all of this in under 3 hours but before
we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an
update from simply learn
so let's start off this tutorial by
understanding the need for the cisp
certification
you would be aware of the various cyber
security certifications like ccna comtia
security plus
cism cisa and ch to name a few
you might have also come across the cssp
certification
let me tell you this is one of the
toughest and most in demand
certification in the cyber security
field
in the current times managing
information security in a company can be
extremely challenging with the advent of
the internet and various other
technologies
there is a large exposure to various
security breaches
the presence of information security
experts in-house helps
organizations manage their i.t processes
in a better way this is where a cisp
professional is in demand by employers
compared to the other cyber security
professionals the demand for cssb
certified professionals has grown
rapidly there are nearly 50
000 job postings for the same now that
you have an idea of the demand of cssp
certified professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly is cisp
cssp stands for certified information
system security professional it is
considered the gold standard in the
field of information security
this certification is taken up by id
professionals it trains a candidate to
become an information assurance
professional
taking up the cssp certification will
help you define the design
architecture controls and management of
highly secure business environments
you will also be called a cssb
professional only after you successfully
pass the cssp exam
so now let's have a look into the cssp
exam requirements
the primary requirement for any
candidate is that they should have at
least
five years of work experience in the
field of information security in
addition to this it is also suggested
that the candidate clears
other certifications like ccna comchair
security plus
ceh casm and cisa to name a few
cssp is considered as an advanced level
cyber security certification
hence it is better if the candidate
clears the basic level and the
managerial level certifications before
moving to the cssp certification
as i mentioned earlier this
certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience
professionals working as security
consultants and managers network and
security architects
i.t directors security auditors and
chief
information security officers can take
up the cssp certification
let's now move on to our next topic that
is cssp domains
this entire certification is grouped
into a total of eight domains
the broad spectrum of topics included in
cssp ensure its relevance across
all disciplines in the field of
information security
successful candidates are competent in
the following eight domains
they are security and risk management
then we have asset security
security engineering communications and
network security
followed by identity and access
management then security assessment and
testing
security operations and finally we have
software development security
these eight domains deal with different
aspects of information security we will
have a look into each of these
individually and understand what each of
these domains symbolize
first up we have the security and risk
management domain
as the name suggests this domain mainly
consists of the fundamentals of security
policies
compliance law and regulations
professional ethics
risk management and threat modeling
cyber security and information security
plays a major role in this domain there
is a difference between
cyber security and information security
which is more often missed out on by
people
cyber security refers to several
techniques used to protect the integrity
of networks
whereas information security refers to
processes
and tools deployed to protect sensitive
information to implement cyber security
we have a list of approaches like
compliance based ad-hoc
and risk-based in compliance based
security measures are decided based on
regulations
while in ad hoc security measures are
based on no specific criteria
in risk-based security measures are
based on unique risks depending on the
organization
let's now have a look at the cia triad
here c stands for confidentiality i
for integrity and a for availability
confidentiality integrity and
availability have served as the industry
standard for computer security since the
time of the first mainframes
confidentiality means that information
and functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties
for example military secrets integrity
means that
information and functions can be added
altered or removed only by authorized
people
and availability means that systems
functions and data must be available on
demand
now that we have understood the cia
triad let's have a look at the grc
trilogy
this trilogy is a structured approach
adopted by organizations to align it
objectives with business
objectives first up we have governance
such a program has motives like ensuring
goals are achieved
providing strategic plans and so on
governance is taken care of by the
senior professionals of an organization
next up we have risk management here the
organization looks into mitigating all
types of risks such as
investment physical and cyber risks
finally we have compliance
as discussed previously compliance
refers to abiding by the defined
laws and regulations so who do you all
think develops a security policy which
is used to achieve the organization's
goals
well it is done by the senior management
of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies
first and foremost these policies should
support the vision and mission of the
company
all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be regularly updated
and finally it is important that these
security policies should be easy to
understand
so that everyone can abide by them
without any problem
in addition to security policies a risk
analysis team is also formed an
organization to perform the analysis of
each known risk
there are various steps to perform risk
analysis let's have a look at each of
these
first the team makes an assessment of
the value of the company's assets
then there is an analysis made based on
the risks to assets
and finally the team discovers solutions
to mitigate these risks
now that was all about the first domain
of cssp security and risk management
let's have a look at the second domain
asset security asset security deals with
the collection
and protection of assets such as data
and devices
here we will be looking into data
classification data management
data remnants and data loss prevention
so in data classification the data owner
classifies data
a data owner can be an individual or a
group of people who created the
information
and are directly responsible for it this
classification is done
based on a set of predefined criterias
at the end the classification is
annually reviewed to see if there has to
be some change
incorporated data management involves
managing the information lifecycle needs
of an enterprise in an effective manner
it also ensures that the data complies
to the set standards
and finally data management also ensures
data validity and integrity
moving on to data remnants it is a term
used for the residual of digital data
that is present even after trying to
erase the data
data remnants should be avoided as data
should be completely destroyed to tackle
data remnants we have methods like
overwriting and destruction to name a
few
in overwriting other information is
written over the data
several times so that the original data
cannot be recovered
in destruction data in the storage
device is physically damaged to make
recovery difficult
asset security also looks into data loss
prevention
here several measures and risk
assessments are performed to ensure that
information is only
available to authorized users let's now
move on to our third domain
security engineering as the name
suggests this domain talks about
security architecture security models
cryptography and physical security
security architecture establishes a
common practice for creating analyzing
and using architecture description
within a particular domain
security architecture takes the help of
tcb that is trusted computing base
security perimeter and reference models
to implement security cryptography is
also a part of security engineering
in cryptography information is secured
by converting data from a readable
format to a non-readable format and vice
versa
moving to our fourth domain we have
communications and network security
this domain is all about network
structures transmission methods and
security measures used to achieve cia in
an organization
osi model is the foundation of
networking this model that is the open
systems interconnection model osi model
describes how data is transferred from
one computer to another
the osi model consists of seven layers
starting from physical layer
then data link layer network layer
transport layer
session layer presentation layer and
finally application layer
in the first layer that is physical
layer transmits raw bit stream over the
physical medium
then data link clear defines the format
of data on the network
network layer provides logical
addressing and it also provides path
determination using local addressing
the fourth layer that is transport layer
provides end-to-end connections
in this layer data is transmitted using
transmission protocols including tcp and
udp
the session layer maintains connections
and it is also responsible for
controlling ports and sessions
the sixth layer that is a presentation
layer ensures that data is in a usable
format
and finally in the seventh layer that is
the in the application layer human
computer interaction happens
here applications can access the network
services
the communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware
or software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer then we also have the ids
ids is known as the intrusion detection
system
this is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system
ids is used together with a firewall and
a router
moving to identity and access management
our fifth domain let's have a look at
what this domain is all about
this domain of cissp is all about the
access control
identification authorization and attacks
on access control
and its counter measures to be able to
access a data set or a resource a
subject has to be identified
authenticated and authorized identity
management kerberos and access criteria
are few of the crucial fields here in
identity management
through automated means users are
identified and authenticated
this domain also speaks of kerberos an
authentication protocol that is based on
symmetric key cryptography
and provides end-to-end security access
to data shouldn't be granted to anyone
and everyone
in fact it should be granted based on
the level of trust
and the job role in the organization it
is also better if it is provided based
on the location
and the time let's now have a look at
our sixth domain security
assessment and testing so in this domain
we will look into audit
security control assessment and testing
reports as you might have heard of the
term audit
it is nothing but a repeated process
wherein an independent professional
evaluates and analyzes evidence then we
have vulnerability assessment
wherein it risks are identified and
evaluated
it helps in identifying quantifying and
prioritizing vulnerabilities
a well-planned and executed assessment
and test strategy
can provide valuable information about
risk and risk mitigation
the assessment and test is executed by a
working group called the integrated
product team
testing is performed to check the data
flow between the application and the
system
up next we have the security operations
domain the seventh domain of csp is all
about
investigations monitoring and logging
disaster recovery and change management
here we will look into the fields of
digital forensics
incident management and perimeter
security investigation of a computer
crime is also known as computer foreign
six
in digital forensics data is examined to
identify
recover and analyze opinions about
digital information
incident management works to restore the
services to normal as soon as possible
a team called the incident response team
is deployed to handle such emergencies
incidence response is defined as a
practice of detecting a problem
determining its costs
minimizing the damage resolving the
problem and documenting each step
this team provides management with
sufficient information and defends the
company against future attacks
in perimeter security there is perimeter
defense which allows us to detect and
keep a check on unauthorized physical
access
this field also controls the access to
the facility moving on to our eighth and
final domain we have
software development security as the
name suggests
this domain talks about security in a
software development lifecycle
here we will be looking into topics like
api malware
spyware adware social engineering
attacks and sql injection attack
let's start off with the application
program interface known as api
api is basically a collection of
protocols and functions used to create
applications
it supports formats such as
representational state transfer
rest and simple object access protocol
rest is nothing but using the present
features of the web in a simple way
and soap which is an acronym for simple
object access protocol is a messaging
protocol for exchanging data among
computers
now let's move on to malware as a
security threat malware is a term which
refers to malicious software
viruses ransomware and worms we can also
call trojan virus as a form of malware
which is capable of disguising itself as
a legitimate software
malware is basically a broad term that
refers to a variety of malicious
programs
one way to protect your software from
malware is to always double check your
downloads
moving on to our next security threat
spyware as the name suggests
this is a software that typically spies
on your system
spyware is also a type of malware which
is used to secretly gather information
of the victim to give it to a third
party
those programs that secretly record all
that you do on your computer
are called spyware it is always advised
to turn on pop-up blockers to prevent
spyware
next up we have adware adware is also
known as
advertising supported software it is a
type of malware that constantly displays
ads and pop-ups
some of such ads can also gather your
information
at times adware is not all that
dangerous but it is a hassle
as it is a gateway to unwanted
advertising on the screen and it can
also change the browser home page
adwares are known to display unwanted
annoying advertisements on your screens
let's now have a look at social
engineering attacks
it is basically the art of manipulating
people so that they end up giving their
confidential information
this attack lures victims into handing
over their confidential data
this attack takes place by tricking the
human mind the most common social
engineering attacks are
fishing spear phishing and wheeling
phishing attack phishing attack is a
practice wherein the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a very
trusted source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and various other login
credentials
spear phishing attack is a variation of
phishing here the attacker targets a
specific individual or a group of people
and in wailing phishing attack wealthy
powerful and prominent
individuals are made targets moving on
to our next attack we have sql injection
attack
sql injection attack is a type of code
injection attack
in a database driven website the hacker
manipulates a standard sql query
it allows attackers to tamper with the
existing data
here malicious code is inserted into the
sql server to obtain information
so in cishb as with every security
course we start off with the cia triad
now here cia
is confidentiality integrity and
availability so
it starts off with every security
mechanism when we talk about security
and we want to keep things secure what
is it that we want to secure
it is the data of an organization that
is the most valuable
asset to the organization and that's
what we want to secure
when we say that we want the data to be
secured we basically talk about
three aspects for that data the first
and the foremost that the data needs to
remain confidential
the second aspect that the trader needs
to be trustworthy
and the third concept that the data
should be available to all authorized
users when and where they require it so
going back to the first point when we
say we want data to be confidential what
do we mean by that by confidentiality we
talk about
the data being made available only to
authorized users after you have
authenticated them
insured or assured of their authenticity
and only then you're going to give
access to that data right so even if you
go into an organization
an organization has a hierarchy of
governance right
so only certain people with certain
clearances or certain job titles can
have access to certain amount of data
whereas other people may not have access
to it for example a person working in
the sales department will not have
access to data that is accessed by the
hr department
thus that's what we are looking at
classification of data and keeping it
confidential only making it available to
those people who
require it when we say trustworthiness
or the integrity of that data
the integrity is where the data has been
altered
modified removed deleted by unauthorized
people so we want to prevent that
which means when we say we want the
integrity intact we want to ensure that
only authorized people
can modify alter or remove data if they
are
allowed to do so so that's where the
authorization and authentication comes
into the picture again and
data needs to be available for me to
safeguard data i can just lock it up in
a safe throw the safe in the depth of an
ocean
and say that the data is secure because
it cannot be leaked out but that data is
no longer available to authorized users
hence the data is useless for me data
would have value when the data remains
confidential has its trustworthiness
intact
and is still available to all the users
that are authorized to access it
so when we talk about security we want
these three aspects to be implemented on
any and every digital asset that the
organization has
and thus once these three points are
guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured
moving on let's talk about information
security information security is the
process of protecting data and
information systems so
in the cia as we talked about it when we
said what do we want to protect we want
to protect all the information assets
or the technical assets that we have
from any of the vulnerabilities that can
be identified so
we want to restrict unauthorized access
and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so
modification of data so the integrity
part and destruction of data destruction
could not only be deleting data but it
could be something like ransomware where
the data gets encrypted so it's still
there it's just not accessible to you
now information security ensures the
implementation of these following
aspects the first and foremost comes
from information security policies which
is the governance aspect of it the
policies are designed to have a
implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processes to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards
or guidelines which are globally
available and based on which we can
start developing our security policies
for example
if i want to develop a security policy
in my organization i might want to
depend on
frameworks like iso 27001 cobit or
something similar once i have these
standards set
i would come back to procedures
procedures being how are these standards
to be executed
right for example in my policies i
ensured that i want
encryption of aes 256 to be implemented
or
rather in the policy i determined that
we want uh encryption to be implemented
on a data set because based on the
classification of those data so in my
policies i would determine how the
classification is going to work how data
is going to be classified
on what parameters and thus once the
data gets classified we are going to
come back to standards where we say
if it is classified as a confidential
data we want to use
encryption to protect that data and we
want aes256 to be
utilized for encryption so how do we go
about it how do we implement the
encryption that's where your procedures
come into the picture
your guidelines are troubleshooting
mechanisms optional documents so if
somebody has trouble following the
procedures they might want to go into
the guidelines and see
how to troubleshoot the scenario that
they are facing baselines
are basically the minimum achievable
target that you want to go with with
these policies
so let's say when i say i want to have a
baseline on a server
where for the server to be published
onto the internet or to be used in
production environment it has to meet a
certain criteria which means i can go
back to the hardware and i can say the
server needs a hardware configuration of
x y and z
let's say a processor a xeon processor
with 16 cores 128 gigs of ram so that's
a baseline that i need for a particular
server
for it to be put into production
environment for a particular use
anything above that is acceptable but
nothing should go below that
then comes the risk management while we
are implementing these policies
procedures
we have those standards in place if we
face any risk during that period or if
we face any threat or a vulnerability is
identified during this period
all these terms we are going to discuss
in a little bit so when we identify
vulnerabilities or threats that's where
our wrists come into the picture the
risk management comes in
saying okay this is a risk that we have
identified and now how do we want to
mitigate the risk then the security
organization comes into the picture the
day-to-day activity of how security is
to be implemented
and for all of these procedures policies
baseline standards to be
implemented to be ensured that there or
to be assured that they are
working properly we need to make our
employees
aware that these policies exist this is
something that they need to follow
thus the awareness or the security
education comes into the picture
here the security education is more
focused on helping
employees adhere to the company policies
and standards rather than educating
employees about security
we don't want to make everybody a
ethical hacker we just want to ensure
them
or we want to assure the organization
that everybody has been warned
about policies procedures security
requirements and they are going to
follow those requirements for example a
password policy where you have to adhere
to
a specific password policy to ensure
passwords are created
at the same time there is another
password policy which says that you
should not share passwords with your
colleagues no matter what so for me for
my employees to follow that
i need to make them aware that these
policies exist and there are repetitions
if they do not follow these particular
policies
so coming back to the governance part
what is governance since you have been
talking about it governance ensures that
the security strategies are aligned with
business objectives
and consistent with regulations so what
does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have
and the baselines that we would have
created so security
has to be comparable right so if i say i
have secured against particular attacks
the attacks
have to be identified and then compared
to those particular attacks i can say i
have mitigated
these activities by having specific
security controls thus i can say that i
am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all these security controls to
see that those security activities are
insured are being implemented and are
performing to the best of their
abilities
that's where your governance comes into
the picture the risks being reduced so
the risk management as also comes under
the governance where you are
looking at newly identified risks and
you are then implementing security
controls that would mitigate these risks
then we are looking at information
security investments appropriately
directed so when i say i want a security
control
which would be a firewall ids ips
antiviruses whatever is required
it needs to have a return on investment
which is
acceptable for the organization you
don't want to spend up too much of money
in security
thus creating losses for the
organization when you say a business
a business objective is always to make
money rather than lose money
so security should be a supporting
feature to the business objectives
where the services are being provided by
the business in a secure manner
in such a way that they can still have a
positive return on investment
on the services that are being provided
and the executive management can
determine the program's effectiveness
this is the major part because we have
to
even in any compliances audits technical
audits we have to prove
that whatever we have implemented
actually works is effective
thus mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective
then you have just wasted a bucket load
of money and have not achieved any
security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls
security controls are measures taken to
safeguard an information system from an
attack
basically for the cia triad the
confidentiality integrity and
availability so
security controls could be
administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what are administrative security
controls
there would be policies procedures that
we have in place so the password policy
becomes an administrative control where
the management has made
everybody aware that the password needs
to meet a particular complexity
should not be shared and thus becomes an
administrative security control a
technical security control would be
where we are implementing this policy
and thus when i try to create a password
there is a software that maps the
password
to the complexity requirements assures
or ensures that the complexity
requirements have been met
and thus allows the password to be
accepted or rejects the password as the
case may be
that is a security control a physical
security control maybe let's say a cctv
camera which you are going to use to
monitor people
and uh ensure that nothing untoward
happens
it's not only against physical crime but
let's say access to a particular room
where nobody is seen tailgating
maybe monitoring a server room which is
very well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access
or purposefully or intently do not
access that area at
all times so these are the three levels
of security controls that can be
implemented to enhance the security of
an organization
then we come to security policies
policies is an overall broad statement
produced by a senior management that
dictates the role of security within the
organization
for example the password policy that we
talked about it just said
that it needs to meet a certain
complexity
which is a broad statement that is being
made by by the management saying
we want to adhere to this policy to
ensure that we do not get
hacked by brute force attacks or
dictionary attacks or whatever it is
the broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization
how it is implemented that's where the
procedures and everything else comes
into the picture it must integrate
security into all business processes so
if
i start creating a policy which shows
that the complexity should be so high
that the password should be at least
20 characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember
those passwords or resetting those
passwords or having technical mechanisms
technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent
security may be too expensive to have so
whatever policies are created they need
to be in
in line with the business processes as
well the policy must be reviewed and
modified periodically or as company
changes
so as and when the company becomes more
mature
and can have more levels of security
they must look at their policies again
and redefine them or as a company grows
or changes market scenarios
or changes business processes these
policies may become redundant so you
want to look at those policies and
implement newer policies or modify the
existing policies to suit the business
processes
in a better manner it must support
vision and mission of the organization
a business once established will always
have a long-term vision
for example the e-tailer example that we
are talking about for me to open a
e-tailer
e-retailing website i don't want it to
be periodic i don't want it to be for a
month or something like that i want to
achieve success in that factor
and i want to create a plan of where i
want to reach let's say in the next five
years
so how do i achieve that that's
something that i need to plan as a
business plan
all my security mechanisms that are in
place should be in alignment with the
business plans business visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform
so that's where the policies come into
the picture policies are always
long-term not short-term documents but
need to be periodically
reviewed and modified as the business
grows or business changes its posture
then looking at compliance compliance
means confirming to a rule such as a
specification policy standard or
law so we have looked at compliance from
a perspective where we talked about iso
27001
or pci dss or those frameworks now these
are not laws
but these are standards of frameworks
that have been created over a period of
time
through experience and these are
targeted towards organizations towards
specific industries
for example pci dss is only towards
finance
organizations where they have payment
gateways in place the iso 27001 is a
more generic policy which can be
implemented by various organizations
hipaa health insurance portability and
accountability act is an american act
that talks about
health related data of its citizens so
these are compliances these may not be
laws
but you need to adhere to these to be
effective and to be
allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics
code of ethics state safety of the
commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere
and be seen to adhere to the highest
ethical standards of behavior therefore
strict adherence to this code is a
condition of certification
what are the ethics protect society the
commonwealth and the infrastructure
act honorably honestly justly
responsibly responsibility
and legally prove diligent and competent
service
to the principles advance and profession
now the code of ethics
are codes created by iic square for the
cissp professional
and you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member they would debar the
member strip them of the
certification and even blacklist them to
based on whatever
ethics they have violated so even before
the exam
you have to go through the code of
ethics you have to accept the code of
ethics
in the exam you may get get up to five
to six questions
just on code of ethics then comes the
legal systems
uh that's where the law comes into the
picture law could differ from country to
country or from region to region
and thus depending on which country you
are in you may need to be aware
of those laws of those countries as far
as cssp is concerned
ise square is concerned they are an
american organization so they would talk
about mostly american laws
and a few european laws or directives as
well
so there are three different laws that
we talk about
civil common and religious laws depends
on the country the culture of that
particular country the information
security professional
should understand the different legal
systems followed internationally
so you also may come across the
classification as civil law
criminal law and law of torts
civil law is basically a law where let's
say a contract has been breached
and it's not criminal in nature you just
want to sue an organization for breach
of contract
criminal law is where something criminal
has happened
under the particular act of that
particular country
like let's say a murder or an attack
that has happened a physical attack
or something got stolen and the third
one was the law of torch where
it's more of a compensatory law where
you can file a case a civil suit demand
compensation
in lieu of the wrongs that have happened
to that particular organization
or that individual then comes the
personal security the person
the other people inside the organization
need access to data to complete their
assigned work and hence have the
potential to misuse these privileges
and thus you should have personal
security as well
now when we talk about hiring practices
for people
most of the organizations perform
background checks and we get confused
why these background checks are being
done
the background checks are essential to
the health of the organization where you
are ensuring that the person is not a
malicious person
has the prerequisite certifications or
the qualifications
have never been debarred or have never
been prosecuted
do not have a criminal background thus
preventing
physical attacks on the organization for
example a
competitor may attempt to place in your
organization a spy
to spy uh to gather information on the
secrets of that organization and report
it back to the competitor
a background check may reveal that this
person was previously employed by a
competitor
and thus you might want to verify that
how that employment got terminated when
did it get terminated or is this person
misusing anything or misrepresenting uh
any aspect of
his or their life then you also need to
get confidentiality agreement signed
with them
for example ndas non-disclosure
agreements
data that is being shared with them the
ownership of that particular data
and what are the repetitions if that
confidentiality is breached
by that particular person conflict of
interest agreements for positions
handling competitive information
as you go higher up in the organization
you might come across contracts where it
prohibits a particular person in
engaging and act into the same activity
with a competitor for a particular
period of time
so if there is a conflict of interest
when you are hiring a person where they
have signed and
such a agreement with another competitor
or another organization
you don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where
uh the other organization may sue you
for hiring a person
while they were still under that
particular contract so it's not only
to look at the background of these
people but to safeguard the organization
from any lawsuits
or any violations of contract as well
get the non-complete agreements for the
positions in charge of unique corporate
processes
that again goes on to say if you're
going to leave the organization you
cannot start up
a competing business similar to the
organization's business and so on so
forth
now let's come back to the technical
aspect and start talking about
vulnerability threats and risk
now what is a vulnerability it is
nothing but a weakness in a system or a
process
implies the absence of a counter measure
vulnerability is internal and is more
easily managed
so it's uh basically a flaw or a
mis-configuration or a design flaw
or something like using defaults
username passwords
configurations where if that
particular flaw is misused it will lead
into
a security event on that particular
device for that particular organization
so when we say a security event it has
to be detrimental in nature so if
somebody is using a weak password that
can easily be cracked
that is a vulnerability where you have
identified a weak password and then you
want to prevent that vulnerability by
imposing a security control
or a counter measure the security
control here starts off with the policy
of having a robust security
policy where a password policy comes in
that describes the complexity of a
particular password
and then you talk about a technical
countermeasure where you have
implemented an identity and access
management plan
which would ensure that the person
creating that password adheres to the
complexity of that particular
policy then a threat the threat is the
possibility that the vulnerability might
be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password
and it has been allowed that's a
vulnerability which can be exploited by
the usage of
brute force attacks or dictionary based
attacks to crack passwords if the
password is cracked somebody
unauthorized may get access to that data
thus resulting in a loss for that
organization
so the threat is the possibility of that
particular
vulnerability being exploited and then
comes the risk
the risk is basically the likelihood of
that attack being happening
so i have a weak password it can be
exploited by
a brute forcer dictionary attack the
likelihood of that attack
is what determines the risk level for me
now the likelihood will always be
hypothetical
but we don't want to run helter skelter
and we do not want to take
uh the possibility to extreme so that's
where your business processes come into
the picture
your security policies come into the
picture based on the business processes
and the policies implemented
if i have a weak password what would be
the loss that i would face
for that particular person for example a
fresher coming into an organization
having a weak password but having
limited access to uh data
would have a lesser risk because of the
loss being lesser
than a ceo of an organization using a
weak password and thus getting exploited
because the ceo will have access to more
proprietary
data that if gets into the competitor's
hand
would lead in huge losses thus
the same risk of having a password
cracked for a fresher
will have a lesser loss thus a lesser
risk compared to the same risk
to a ceo where the loss would be higher
so a threat
could also be in multiple aspects
threats could be natural
that means to fires flooding tornadoes
anything that is an act of god that can
happen with minimal human interaction
or the second threat would be man-made
where man is responsible for it like
theft hacking writing
war anything that is created by a man or
rather humans
and technical in nature could be
software bugs where vulnerabilities
create
are created or server failures where
something technical has gone wrong and
you need a technical as
skilled person to come in and repair
that particular
aspect then the fourth one would be a
supply system failure or a chain supply
failure where you have dependencies for
example
any organization will have a dependency
on an electricity service provider
where they are providing electricity as
a service which powers on the id
infrastructure
if the service broader fails and there
is electricity
or a power cut your systems are not
going to work
thus you need a secondary mechanism to
prevent that threat from being realized
once we have identified these threats we
have identified these vulnerabilities
and we have identified the likelihood
and the probability of that attack
that's where we come across the risk
management exercise now what is risk
management
risk management is a hypothetical
exercise where we have identified a
vulnerability we have looked at the
threat that it may have
and the likelihood of that threat being
realized
once we have identified the threat uh
the risk level
that's where the risk management comes
into the picture reading from the slides
a core component of enterprise security
program
why because we need a baseline and we
compare security to a baseline
for example i've got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when i do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the
vulnerability assessment gives me a
report that states that
some of the rules may now be redundant
thus allowing access to unauthorized
users
this becomes a risk or this becomes a
threat if this threat is identified by
unauthorized people they would then try
to attack this firewall to gain access
to that
data which they are unauthorized to
access does
leading to losses for an organization
what is the likelihood of this happening
if the likelihood is high or low that's
what the risk management program is all
about
right and based on this risk we
implement security controls
we manage the security controls and then
we verify the security controls
for future risks to coming into the
picture it must be defined and it is
always defined as an ongoing project
because risks will always change based
on the businesses
based on the security controls that you
have this will give a guidance to an
organization
of how security is being implemented how
it has
enhanced over a period of time and how
security mature that organization has
become because of the risk assessment
program
it also helps you to satisfy two aspects
due diligence and due care
what is due diligence due diligence is
basically
the research that organization does in
identifying those risks and mitigating
them
the due care is the actual part of
mitigation where you have implemented a
security control
to mitigate the risk that you have
identified so if companies negligent
that means if the company doesn't have a
risk management program
it is not going to be that security
oriented
or the security is not going to be that
great does the company may not comply
to laws regulations and standards thus
causing them penalties
lawsuits and other reputations in the
industry based on whatever they are
doing
for risk management we come to
frameworks the frameworks are used to
categorize information systems so that
we can identify
threats or risks based on the
classification so this classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality
it basically gives us an understanding
of the value of the asset that we have
so if you go back to domain one the
asset value or the asset identification
asset security
that's where it comes into the picture
obviously a database server is going to
be more secure
than an end user laptop based on the
data that they have
thus the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher
than the end user's laptop then we look
at the security controls that can be
implemented
then for those the frameworks like iso
27001 comes into the picture
there is kobe there is there are a lot
of frameworks out there nist 800 iphone
53
then we talk about assessing the
security controls once we have placed
those security controls we need to
verify those controls are placed
properly
they actually mitigate the risk and are
appropriate
to correctly mitigate that particular
risk that they are created
then looking at authorizing information
systems grant information systems
operations based on risk determined so
you have identified risks you have
authorizing
some of them some of the devices to
function in a particular manner
based on which some of those risks would
be mitigated or would be reduced to an
acceptable level
so in the cissp we talk about a lot of
risk assessment strategies we look at
how we can
manage risks the four different types of
managing risks would be
one is to mitigate other is to transfer
the third is to accept it and the fourth
one
is to neglect the risk so in the cissp
it talks in great details about those
risk assessment strategies
we are talking about the four types of
risk mitigating strategies
they are risk avoiding or avoiding the
risks
accepting the risk transferring the risk
and eliminating the risk so
uh in the course we basically talk about
a lot of
risk strategies and how to mitigate
these risks and
how they can be implemented to bring
down to an acceptable level so again
risk
acceptance risk appetite of an
organization comes into the picture
these terms are then discussed
uh in the training to understand how the
policies would work around
the risk management strategy moving on
then looking at monitoring security
control so once we have security
controls in place we have assist them we
also need to monitor them
for the effectiveness and though they're
going to create any alerts
or any risks are being realized or any
new risk that may be created by the
security
control implementation so in these risk
assessment
these are the frameworks these are the
steps that we want to follow to identify
mitigate and
monitor these risks so the management
begins with risk assessment
what do you mean by risk assessment
identifying the impact of the risk that
the risk would have on the organization
and there would be two different ways to
assess the risk
a quantitative assessment or a
qualitative assessment
a quantitative assessment is more
quantifiable or is numerical in
in its process where you're looking at
assigning costs
to particular assets and the threats so
the losses that you may figure out in a
risk assessment strategy
would be more numerical where would be
in a currency format
where let's say a risk if realized would
lead to a loss of
a extra amount of dollars that's where
the quantitative analysis comes into the
picture
the qualitative analysis would be
quality of a service so if a service is
being affected because of a risk what is
the degradation of that service to what
aspect is
is it getting degraded for example
internet that we use
if there is an internet outage or if
there is a reduction in internet speed
right so if i've got a 10 mbps line and
now because of some fault of the isp it
gets reduced to 4 mbps
i may not be able to conduct the
business that i would i was doing on a
10 mbps line
thus the quality of that device has
degraded uh does it is going
does it is a risk and it is causing me
losses right
so qualitative risk analysis would be
more descriptive in nature
rather than be numerical in nature uh
most of the
companies or organizations would follow
a hybrid policy
because it is not possible to have a
quantitative quantitative risk analysis
in each and every scenario
new organization which doesn't have much
data to rely on historical data
of how threats have affected that
particular organization may go in for a
qualitative one
and as they mature over time in the
security practices they may then turn
over
to a quantitative risk analysis or a
hybrid risk analysis
where they're using a combination of
quantitative and qualitative both
thus uh the risk controls that we were
talking about risk acceptance risk
reduction
and risk assignment uh there is risk
avoidance as well
so there are four controls the risk
reduction is where you have implemented
a security control
based on which the risk has been reduced
to a more acceptable level
risk assignment is where you're also
known as
risk avoidance that's where you're
avoiding risk by outsourcing it
so talking about risk controls again the
four types being
accept avoid transfer and reduce
risk acceptance is where uh your
the organization is willingly accepting
the risk as the way it is
because they don't want to deal with it
right now they might deal it with it in
the next iteration
or it doesn't it is at an acceptable
level and the company just wants to move
on
avoiding the risk is where you are going
to try to
not use the service where the risk
exists thus
avoiding is where you have identified a
particular service where the risk exists
and now you're not using the service
to avoid the risk altogether risk
limitation or risk reduction
would be where you are implementing a
security control to mitigate the risk
and then risk transference is where risk
assignment comes into the picture
where you are transferring it to a third
party like outsourcing it by using
insurance
to limit the risk so for example the
threat is of a fire
the risk is high but you cannot do
anything about it
so you purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens
you would still be reimbursed for the
losses that you have uh faced
coming back to counter measures we have
discussed administrative uh
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws customs
that a company needs to adhere to based
on the industry that they are in
then there are technical controls
software controls anything that is
technical in nature ids ips firewalls
encryption
anything that is going to help you
implement the cia
and then physical where you would look
at locks on those
security guards at offenses where
they're preventing access
to unauthorized people let's talk about
roles and responsibilities of management
now as far as management is concerned or
the hierarchy is concerned
you can see on the screen there's a
senior management the security
professional data owner custodian and
user now these are from
exam perspective from the certification
perspective obviously the hierarchy in
an organization
would be slightly different but here the
senior management
is the responsible party for the entire
security mechanism
so they must drive the entire security
pro exam so cissp
talks about a top-down approach where
the senior management
has realized the importance of security
and is implementing at all levels
within the organization thus they are a
part of it
and they are supporting the security
program
they define the tolerance of risk of how
much risk is stopping to be tolerated by
an organization
from a monetary perspective or the
qualitative perspective as well
depending on the laws legislations
regulations compliances
and the contracts the business has
signed they will rely on security
professionals to manage the risk
but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined
by the senior management once the
security team comes up with
counter measures the senior management
either approves or disapproves them
based on the return on investment of
that counter measure
the security professional assist with
the development of policy documents
gives their input
because they are the people who are in
the day-to-day process of dealing with
these
thus they can identify gaps and give
good inputs
to modify or to create the policy in a
more robust manner
the security professionals may be a part
of the risk assessment and risk
management team as well
especially uh the security technical
aspects of it
assist with the implementation and
maintenance of countermeasures so the
administrative
technical or physical measures that you
have identified
you may be requested to implement that
for example
the locks that we have on the door the
swipe locks
they are connected to a database where
the database is maintained
so as a security professional you
wouldn't be responsible to fit those
locks
but to create the database manage and
maintain the database where that
information
is kept upon where people are authorized
and authenticated
and would be responsible for monitoring
auditing and
security assessments as well the data
owner the owner of that particular data
part
uh would normally be the head of the
department for example the sales data is
normally owned by the
director of sales of that department so
that they would be ultimately
responsible
for identifying that data classifying
that data and
accepting the security controls that are
implemented they may request for
additional security controls if they
deem fit the security professional
implements these security controls
then the custodian a person who is
responsible
for implementing the approved security
controls or managing the day-to-day
activity of the security controls
for example the security professional
has identified an access control to be
implemented
on a data set that the data owner owns
the data owner has approved of it
it is the custodian who is going to
implement that strategy
or implement the control uh on it the
user
is basically the user who or the person
who accesses the information and id
resources
does whatever access controls have been
implemented would identify the user
authenticate
authorize them and help them accountable
for whatever
they are doing if the user is unable to
authenticate access would be denied
we will focus on the second domain of
cssp which is
asset security so let's understand the
need for asset security through a small
scenario
well it was yet another regular day in
tim's organization
everything was going on fine until the
organization faced a cyber attack
the hacker hacked all the servers in
tim's organization
the organization had loads of data not
all of the data had the same level of
protection
the level of protection varied from one
piece of information to another
in this scenario the hacker could hack
into only that particular data which was
less protected
however this cyber attack had a huge
impact on the organization
in addition to this it was also
discovered that there was
some flaw in the information
classification process
that exposed even sensitive data to a
cyber attack
in other words even crucial data was
left with very less protection
this gave rise to asset security asset
security is defined as the process of
collecting
and protecting assets such as data and
devices
asset security helps an organization
understand
and classify data with respect to its
importance
which in turn makes sure that highly
valuable data receives the most
protection
asset security achieves its goals
through its domains
the domains are information
classification
then we have data classification data
life cycle
data remnants and finally we have data
loss prevention
each of these domains have different
goals all of these domains together make
up asset security
now let's have a look at each of these
domains individually
first up we have information
classification as you saw what happened
in tim's organization it is understood
that
importance of data varies largely we
have to classify data before we can move
on to protecting it
we need to be able to identify which is
the most crucial data with respect to
organizations
information classification is defined as
a process of
segregating data based on its importance
to provide adequate level of protection
to
every piece of data information
classification is different for each
sector
based on their objectives the
classification varies
in the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information
whereas in the government or military
sector it is used to prevent
unauthorized access and finally in the
commercial sector it is used to keep
sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors
let's now move on to our second domain
that is data classification
as the name suggests here data is
basically classified based on a set of
considerations
here we will look into factors like data
retention requirements
then data security requirements data
disposal methods
data encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements
so these are the factors which are taken
into consideration
while classifying data this entire
process of data classification is taken
care of by the data
owner in addition to the classification
they also
analyze the use and value of the
available data to the company finally
the data
owner also annually reviews the data
classification
before classifying data an important
step is to understand the data life
cycle
all of us speak of data all the time
however do we know the various steps a
piece of data goes through
well for that let us have a look at the
third domain data lifecycle
we will start off from the data creation
step and understand
what happens to the data after that as
you see on your screens we have six
steps in the data lifecycle stage
they are create store use
share archive and destroy starting off
with the create phase
this is the first step in data life
cycle
here new data is generated or the
existing data
is updated after the data is created we
use
data repositories to store the created
data
without storing data we cannot derive
any information from
it hence this step is very crucial in
the third phase
data is viewed or used in some
application
or processed in addition to data being
viewed and processed
it is also shared between various users
and customers
our fifth face is archive here data
which is not used frequently that is
inactive data is identified and then
moved into long-term storage systems
and finally we have the destroy face as
the name suggests
data is simply destroyed here data can
be destroyed either
digitally or physically not to forget
you cannot simply destroy data
it should be done based on regulations
but have you wondered what happens if
data is not destroyed even after we try
our best to erase it
well this gives rise to data remnants in
simple words data remnants
is a term used for the residual of
digital data
which remains even after attempting to
erase that particular data
data remnants should be avoided as it is
not good to have
remains of a piece of data which was
intended to be destroyed
security professionals should be
well-versed with techniques to avoid
data remnants
so how do we tackle data remnants for
this we have various methods
they are purging clearing overwriting
degaussing storing and finally
destruction
let's have a look at each of these
methods individually and understand how
they help in
tackling data remnants first up we have
purging
purging is done to minimize risks on
crucial information
in clearing data from storage devices
are removed
however it can be reconstructed by using
various softwares
third we have overwriting here we write
over the original data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered
de-gauzing is the method used to destroy
data on magnetic storage tapes
next up we have storing before storing
data on media
the data is encrypted for the purpose of
safety
finally the sixth method is destruction
here
storage device which hold the data are
physically damaged
incineration crushing and shredding a
few of the methods used for destruction
now let's move on to our fifth domain
data loss prevention
in this domain various security measures
are adopted that will help in making
data available to only the authorized
users
here we will look into four of such
measures
the first measure is data inventory in
this step
data is identified and then classified
in the second step the data flow is
plotted over the life cycle
the third measure is data protection
strategy
here a number of risk assessments are
performed
the fourth measure is implementation in
this step
we take up cases which have had a
history of data loss for testing purpose
those were the five domains under asset
security in addition to these it is also
required that we understand the term
privacy with respect to asset security
privacy is a very crucial aspect when it
comes to vested security
information privacy and data privacy are
more or less the same
this term is used to differentiate one
person from another
it relates to the personal data stored
on computers
so what kind of data falls under this
category
well we have data such as medical
records office data financial data
etc which fall under this category to
uphold privacy we use technologies like
pseudonymization
tokenization and anonymization well
pseudonymization refers to a data
management process
anonymization refers to a process of
either encrypting or removing
personally identifiable data so that
people who the data describes remain
anonymous and finally in tokenization
a sensitive piece of data is substituted
with a non-sensitive equivalent
cissp stands for the certified
information security
or rather certified information system
security professional
it is considered as a gold standard in
the field of information security
it is a management certification so when
you are in the senior management
this is the kind of certifications that
you would require for your
management skills now this is a
non-technical or a semi-technical
certification here it's nothing about
vulnerability assessment or penetration
testing
you're not going to do anything hands-on
you are not expected to know hacking
or you are not expected to know how to
configure firewalls anti-viruses and
whatnot
it's basically something that over a
period of
years of experience you have evolved a
certain understanding
of how security policies should be
constructed how they should be
implemented
and how security affects an organization
so here you
are responsible to create a overall
security policy for an organization to
help
maintain the security posture of an
organization now as far as the
certification is concerned it has a
validity of three years
after which you don't have to give the
exam again however during these three
years you have to
earn a certain point so it is known as a
continuing
education points that isc square allows
you to
generate points by attending lectures or
by attending webinars by
publishing white papers by providing
trainings obviously all of these should
be authorized and you should have
a validation from a authorized party
that you have done this activity once it
is verified you will be awarded certain
points
once you have collected sufficient
number of points
you will retain your certification
beyond three years the passing rate of
this exam is less than 50
so it's not how much you require to
score what this basically tells you is
the
amount of people who actually clear the
exam in the first attempt now let's not
get disheartened because of this
essentially the exam is quite tough it's
known as a mild white an
inch deep exam that means you need to
know just about everything and anything
that is there to be known in information
security and that's something that we
are going to discuss when we go into the
eight domains
of cissp what happens is there are a lot
of people who are not actually prepared
for the exam who think they are prepared
attempt the exam
and sadly fail in their first attempts
some people just misjudge the exam and
not prepared for it
so the fact that i'm trying to put
across is be very well prepared i have
seen people who study for
months together attempt a lot of
questions ensure that their knowledge is
up to the mark and only then
do they attempt the exam anybody can
register for the exam to be honest and
clear the exam as well however to get
certified there are two different
avenues
so if you have a experience of at least
five years
in two of the domains that are in the
cissp course you get
certified so even if you clear the exam
there is a validation process that
happens after the exam where you have to
submit documentation
to prove to isc square that you have
that
level of experience and once it is pro
proven and validated
you get certified as a cissp if you do
not have that five years of experience
you get certified as an associate of iic
square for cissp
and they give you six years during which
you can achieve the level of experience
prove it to them and then get certified
as a cissp
so you can see the stringent levels that
are taken for this certification
the validation is basically
documentation and proof that you have to
submit and which is verified
so even after you clear an exam to get
validated and get certified
it can take up to five to six weeks for
isc square to
validate and provide you with the
certification with that let's go
and see the exam let's have an overview
of what the exam is all about
the governing body is isc square that's
what we have been referring to
and the professional experience at least
four years of
college degree or additional credentials
from isc squares
approved list that will satisfy one year
of required experience
and five years of paid full-time work
experience in two or more domains
like i said anybody can give the exam
register for it
attempt it once you clear then that's
where the criteria of your work
experience comes into the picture you
prove five years of experience probably
by a letter from your organization
from your hr saying you have this kind
of experience that is relevant to the
certification
they will isis square will validate it
you get the certification
if you don't have that experience you
get associate of ic square
and then you get six years to attain
that level of experience after which you
can get certified
the exam fees what 699 dollars
so it's an expensive exam a single
attempt for each voucher
so if you fail that's another 700 for
the second attempt
the fact being if you fail for the first
time you cannot
attempt the exam for the next 30 days if
you fail for the second time
you cannot attempt the exam again for
the next 60 days and if you fail for the
third time you cannot attempt the exam
for another 90 days
so there's a cooling off period after
each attempt so i would suggest study
hard
go for the first attempt clear it and
nail it the maintenance fees for your
certification
is again 85 us dollars for three years
the exam length is three hours
and the questions could vary from 100 to
150
150 being the max questions that can be
asked in that exam
you can clear the exam well before 150
questions
so be prepared for that as well but
imagine when you're walking into that
exam
bear in mind that you will be asked 150
questions
and you have to time those in three
hours 180 minutes that's what three
hours is so
if you do the math not much time for
every question so it's just a minute and
a
half
or less than that for each question and
the questions could be very descriptive
could be confusing so you have to have
your
mental faculties really strong during
the exam the passing score
is 700 out of a possible 1000 points
exam language is english testing centers
there are isc square authorized
centers where you need to book that exam
there's a huge process that you have to
follow too
where you go for the exam itself so once
you have
registered on the isc square portal and
you purchase the voucher
they will give you a list of centers in
your vicinity that you can
look into they'll give you a calendar to
give you the possible dates that you can
attempt the exam on
select the center select the date reach
the center at least half an hour
before the scheduled time there is a
verification so you have to carry your
identification a government issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to
prove that you are who you say you are
and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam
the question formats are three types
multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that we are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions
it's the same they give you a question
they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen they will specify
if there is more than one answer to that
particular question in a drag and drop
it's most like
more like match the following so there
will be a column a and column b
and uh they'll ask you a question and
say okay column a gives you the options
drag and drop whichever correct answer
is in c is from column a to column b
and then submit the answer if the answer
is correct you get awarded the points
else there is no negative marking the
third is a hotspot
a hotspot question is basically a
diagram let's say a architectural
diagram that will be presented to you
and they will ask you to pinpoint a
certain aspect within that diagram for
example
they may give you an architectural
overview of a network of how it has been
established and they will ask you
for a network-based firewall which is
the most
likeliest area that you want the
firewall to be placed in
so you don't need to know how to
configure the firewall but from an
architectural perspective you need to
know
where that firewall needs to be placed
for it to be the most effective
for the given scenario in the question
these are the domains that are asked so
you can see it
basically covers anything and everything
that is there in information security
it starts off with security and risk
management which weighs 15 percent
in your questions in your exam so if
your exam is 115 questions
15 would be around we'll have around 20
22 odd questions
and risk management being one of the
most important topics
for these kind of certifications then uh
asset security which covers 20 10
of your questions so that's around 15
questions security architecture and
engineering this is where your
infrastructural knowledge
uh your security architecture your
enterprise architecture all those come
into the picture
there are a lot of theoretical models
that you need to study in domain three
and that covers 13 of your exam
communications and network security this
is the most
technical topic within all these eight
topics this is where you talk about
networks you talk about tcp
you discuss protocols like tcp udp you
discuss different attacks
management attacks toss attacks and this
basically has 14 percent of weightage
then you have identity and access
management which basically talks about
users subjects objects subject being the
user object being the resource
and a relationship between these to be
created where
people are authorized for some activity
authenticated
and only then allowed and also held
accountable for whatever activity they
have done
then you go into security assessment and
testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration test
software test testing sas tasked a
little bit
all those will be covered in domain
number six which has 12 percent
weightage
then security operations so security
operation center or the stock
day-to-day management of incidents so
your incident management would come into
the picture problem management
change management all of those things
would come under domain seven
as security operations which has 13 of
weightage and then finally
software development security now you
don't need to know
development or you don't need to know
any programming there are no program
based questions they're not going to ask
you how to code
they're going to ask you how to manage a
software development life cycle
or a secure software development
lifecycle so this is where your
waterfall models modified waterfall
models spiral
agile devops devsecops all come into the
picture
and this has 10 percent of weightage now
it is near about impossible for everyone
or anyone to get experience across all
these domains so you will have your
strong points and you will have your
weak points
the task is to identify where you're
good at
understand those things make the maximum
amount of it then identify your weak
points and start developing on
those if you are able to look at it from
a theoretical perspective however if you
can get an internship
or if you can get a you can say just an
insight of how
it works in the practical world it would
be very helpful now
that being said as far as cissp exam is
concerned
it involves a very ideal world the real
world actually doesn't come into the
question because the real world will
have a lot of business logic to it by
business logic
what do we mean every organization will
modify
their projects based on the expertise
that they have based on
the talent that they have and based on
the people
or the hierarchy of the organization
that has been established so
it can be customized to each and every
organization
since an exam cannot deal with these
kind of customizations
we deal with an ideal world so for the
cissp exam we assume
that we have all the resources we have
all the people that are required
we have an hierarchy in the training
which is given out where we have
rules for each and every person and job
titles for each and every person
right so when we go through the training
it is very essential
that we understand what these job roles
are what their responsibilities
are so that when we get those questions
we can identify which person is going to
attempt what
in the real world things are very
different we piggyback we take on
multiple responsibilities
and that is something that cissp doesn't
adhere to so you have to be very careful
identify the job roles identify the
responsibilities
have that map the hierarchical map
created very well
and then try to implement the ideal
world scenario from the cissp standards
to see what is going to
happen that being said let's move on
let's discuss the domains
now these domains we've already seen
what we can do is we are going to move
on to the sample questions for each and
every domain
once we reach the domain we'll see what
the topics in that domain are we'll look
at the sample questions
then we will look and go to the next
domain see the topics in that domain
and then look at the sample questions as
well so what to study
and those sample questions revolving
them so looking at the first
module or first domain security and risk
management
now this is one of the largest domains
that could be
debatable for me i would say the largest
domain could be domain number three
security architecture and engineering
uh could also be domain number four
because it is quite technical
communications and network security
and could also be security operations
because that's
incident management change management
problem management altogether but
each domain is very important from the
exam's perspective
if you're thinking about keeping a
domain for options forget it
that's not the right way to address the
exam let's start off with the first one
security and
risk management this domain teaches you
all about information systems management
and this talks about risks and
everything so
what we are going to do is we are just
going to go to the official document
from ise square
where these domains and their topics are
given
so that's the exam outline from cis
from ic square towards cissp this is the
latest document that is there
available online you can see the url in
my browser
address bar and these are the eight
domains
there's the exam three hours number of
questions 100 to 150
multiple choice and advanced innovative
questions that's where the drag and drop
and the hotspot comes into the picture
though
based on experience i can tell you that
90
of your questions will be multiple
choice 10 would either be drag and drop
and hotspots passing grade is 700 out of
1000 points
exam language availability is english
those who want to attempt in other
languages it is available but
then the exam is 6 hours and the
questions are 250. so
that's your option depending on which
language you're most comfortable with
we are going to go with english that's
the language options coming in cisp
union exam
6 hours 250 questions everything else
remains the
same these are the languages supported
french german brazilian portuguese
spanish japanese simplified chinese and
korean the weightage i guess remains the
same
and that's the first domain security and
risk management
so what does it pertain to understand
and apply concepts of cia
confidentiality integrity and
availability
in the first video we have gone through
all the eight domains at quite
some length we have discussed what cia
is all about
and how the interrelationship is so if
you want a deep dive or
rather a deeper dive than what we are
doing for the domains
go back to the first video look into
that and then you can come back to this
video again
so evaluate and apply security
governance principles so we have to
understand what governance is
now governance is basically having a
overlying architectural security policy
that can be integrated with an
enterprise architecture and
thus having your security policy in
alignment with the business goals and
objectives
security should never become a hindrance
for a business security should always
become a supporting feature
which should allow the business to be
executed in a secure manner
so as a security expert our first goal
is to identify what the business does
what the business processes are
what is the business trying to achieve
and then we try to create a security
policy revolving these
to enhance the business functionality uh
in a
overall picture so you're looking at
organizational processes
acquisitions divestitures acquisition is
when let's say scenarios
where you're trying to create a security
governance policy
now the business is trying to change
because they're trying to acquire
another organization
and merge it within this organization
and now your security policy should
encompass
not only your organization but the newly
acquired organization
let's say the next five years a business
decides that the newly acquired
organization
is no longer profitable and they want to
sell it off and now that's where the
diversity comes into the picture
you are now trying to separate the
entity that you have just
integrated in your security policy and
you are now trying to separate it
with confidentiality integrity and
availability of the company's data
intact without affecting the
organization at any point in time
understand the fact that security is not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time
during business uh continuity and
business let's say
business as usual kind of activities so
that's where your security control
frameworks would come in you're going to
talk about iso 27001
are going to talk about cobit uh pci dss
nist 800 series and so on so forth and
the most two
important statements or terms in the
cissp is due care and due diligence do
you care
is you doing your own research to
identify what security controls
need to be implemented or what kind of
governance needs to be implemented
and due diligence is you yourself
spending that much time
money effort into implementing those
decisions that you have come come
across during the due care thus
enhancing the security
functions of an organization so when we
talk about business requirements
for a business to be effective at the
same time it needs to be legal
it needs to be compliant to regulations
and
laws and to the contracts that have been
created by the organization
so as far as the concept goes when we
say that
security needs to be in alignment with
the business
requirements the business requirements
imply that the business is legal
is compliant to regulations is compliant
to their contractual obligations
and is following standards that have
been prescribed to them so all of them
come together and that's where your
security mapping comes into the picture
we are looking at legal and regulatory
issues like cyber crimes and data
breaches
licensing and intellectual property
requirements and so on so forth
and it will also include isa square's
code of professional ethics now this is
a document apart from
the eight domains that we have talked
about does what does this
document talk about this is the
prescription from iic square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional
expect around four to five questions
from professional ethics as well so not
only is this a document that you need to
read and adhere to
you will be questioned upon this in your
exam and these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well
and then your organization will have its
own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy ic squares
ethics comes
first so your organizational ethics
should not be contradictory to ic
squares ethics in the first place
then develop document and implement
security policies standards procedures
and guidelines identify analyze and
prioritize business continuity
requirements so here that's where your
risk assessment comes into the picture
if you're looking at a particular risk
that means a particular vulnerability
has been identified you want to
see the likelihood of that vulnerability
being exploited and then the business
impact analysis that it may have
based on which you would then create a
plan
to mitigate that particular risk by
having a business continuity or a
disaster recovery plan coming into the
picture
now this is as far as this domain is
concerned you're calculating the risk
it doesn't actually tell you how to
mitigate that risk that's when you go
into the next
future domains and discuss those
technicalities so
you can see uh contribute and enforce
personal security policies
now the thing about cissp is physical
security also comes into the picture
why because if uh hardware is not well
protected there would be physical
attacks social engineering attacks that
could be created
which would lead to data leakage as well
and the first and the foremost
most valuable asset of an organization
is always human
personnel so cissp would also deal with
people protection in the first place for
example protecting people against social
engineering attacks making them aware
about these attacks
if there are natural calamities you have
to plan a
plan for them during your disaster
recovery and business continuity plan
and ensure that people are safeguarded
not only that you have to tie these
things up with identity and access
management for example
account creation account management
onboarding of employees
off-boarding termination of employees
third-party contractors
consultants that you're going to hire
which are not employees but third
parties coming in
to your organization providing
intelligence and so on so forth so all
of those come into the picture as well
and then that's where your risk of
management concepts come in it gives you
a very good overview of how to identify
those risks
and so on so forth now this is what the
in the first domain is all about
it itself is very huge and as we go
ahead we can tie this
domain to the rest of the domains for
more deeper analysis go to the first
video
and then we can come back to this so
let's start with the questions
the first question now these are very
short one-liner questions your exams
would be more descriptive
to be very honest with you if you go
online no matter what practice questions
that you try or
whatever dumps if you can find those you
will find none of them will be
ever any close to the actual exam
questions
you will find a lot of sites online that
sell you cissp dumps with 100
guarantee for you to clear don't fall
for that it's just a money making scam
those questions will be similar
questions something that will give you
an insight about what the exam is going
to be
but when you attempt the exam you will
find out that those questions
are very different from the actual exam
itself coming back to the questions the
primary goal of security awareness
program is now what is the security
awareness program and why is it created
the primary goal
so is it to provide a platform for
disclosing exposure and risk analysis to
make
everyone aware of potential risk and
exposure to provide accurate risk and
exposure results
a way of communicating security
procedures now the answer to this
is to make everyone aware of potential
risk and exposure doesn't mean that you
are trying to make everybody a ethical
hacker
what you're trying to do is in your
organization you are trying to create a
security awareness program
which allows your employees to know what
kind of policies exist in your
company what rules need to be followed
what are the procedures that need to be
followed for them to safeguard
themselves and company assets as well
and ensure that data leakage and data
loss are kept at a minimum so you're
basically trying to make everyone aware
of the
risks that they may have for example
social engineering
not clicking on links not going to
unwanted sites and so on so forth
question two a contingency plan should
address which of the following potential
risks residual risks are identified risk
now what is a potential risk a potential
risk is something that you
may foresee in the future something that
may exist
a residual risk will come to that what
is an identified risk
a risk that has been identified is known
to the organization
and the organization is aware of it so
potential is something that may come
into the future
identified as something that exists
right now a residual risk on the other
hand
is a risk that was identified earlier on
mitigated
but after mitigation there is still a
amount of residual risk that exists so
these terminologies need to be
understood really well
for uh let me give you an example of a
residual risk so let's say there's a
sequel and
injection a flaw that has been
identified in an application
and that's a now that's now an
identified risk now
you've got two options in front of you
go through a software development
lifecycle again
record that part of the application to
mitigate the risk or else have a
security control like a firewall a web
application firewall watching that risk
now the ideal scenario would be that you
go through the development process again
but that is going to take time
so you put in a compensatory control uh
that is a web application firewall in
the meanwhile to mitigate that risk
and then have the recoding done and then
later on resolve the risk all together
so when we put in the firewall to
mitigate the risk temporarily
is the risk actually addressed no there
is still a possibility of a sequel
injection attack happening but we just
have it mitigated to a certain extent
because there is a firewall watching it
so that means that there is still a
residual risk a risk that is remaining
even after me integrate implementing the
security protocol or the security
control that is what a residual risk is
something that remains even after i put
in a security control
which can be taken care of later on or
can be accepted and just moved upon
so coming back to the question a
contingency plan should address which of
the following either a potential risk
a residual risk an identified risk or
all of the above and the current answer
to that is
a residual risk what is a contingency
plan a contingency plan is
i still have a security control but
something may go wrong and for that i
want a secondary control
to be in place to ensure if that if the
first control fails the second control
would still be able to identify that
and stop the security incident happening
so
we are looking at residual risks and
then having contingency plan to
manage those residual risks question
three when the cost of the counter
measures
outweigh the cost of the risk the best
way to handle the risk is to
reject the risk transfer the risk accept
the risk or reduce the risk
now there are four ways a risk can be
managed right accept the risk
avoid the risk transfer the risk or
mitigate the risk
right rejecting the risk is not an
option but what is the question
cost of a counter measure outweighs the
cost of the risk so what is the cost of
a risk the
cost of a risk is basically the impact
that the organization is going to face
in a monetary manner if the risk is
realized
to mitigate that we have a counter
measure in place so if
in the previous example i have
identified a sequel injection attack
and the countermeasure to that is me
implementing a security control a web
application firewall to mitigate that
risk
however if somebody executes that risk
somebody does a sequel injection attack
the loss that
i'm facing is only a hundred dollars
per incident and the maximum incidence
that can happen in a year
are 10 so 10 into 100 is 1 000
per annum is what that risk is going to
cost me for me to implement
a web application firewall on an annual
level it is going to cost me let's say
fifteen thousand dollars in licenses
management salaries and all of those
things
which means that i'm facing a loss of
one thousand dollars but i'm spending
fifteen thousand dollars to prevent that
loss i rather have the thousand dollar
loss than spend fifteen thousand dollars
right so in this scenario the cost of
the counter major is outweighing
the cost of the risk by fourteen
thousand dollars so in this scenario
which is the best way i would do it
either reject the risk which is never an
option because you cannot reject the
risk transfer risk what is transferring
your risk
transferring it to a third party by
purchasing insurance examples
right so if i purchase insurance saying
if this
uh if this gets compromised it's the
insurance company is going to
make the payments and safeguard it or
accept the risk or reduce the risk
so in this scenario accepting the risk
is basically accepting the risk the way
it is
moving on because there is nothing that
you can do about the risk and you're
willing to accept the risk
rather than spend money on it and reduce
the risk is mitigating the risk by
implementing the firewall
and spending that money and then
incurring those losses so
the best answer out of this is accepting
the risk
why can't i transfer the risk because
there is no such insurance where i can
in the given example where i can get
that kind of an insurance policy
reducing the risk would entail me
spending that fifteen thousand dollars
to mitigate the thousand dollar risk
does incurring a fourteen thousand
dollar loss which is against the
business logic
a business needs to make money not spend
money and
that's the fourth option that's left
that's accepting the risk which means
we are not going to implement the
firewall because it is outweighing
the cost of the risk we're just willing
to accept the risk itself and move on
that's the first domain moving on to the
second which is asset security
consists of topics about physical
requirements of information security
let's go back to the document in hand
so moving on to domain two asset
security
we talk about assets assets could be now
okay let's get into the definition of
what an asset is asset could be anything
that has a monetary value associated
with it from the organization's
perspective it could be data
it could be virtual assets it could be
physical assets it could be
anything and everything it could be a
license right you purchase an operating
system
the operating system comes with a
virtual license that installs on your
machine or
is associated with an email address even
that license as a value
does even that license will become a set
so the basic definition is anything and
everything that
is owned by the organization and has a
monetary value associated with it right
thus you're going to
we talk about asset classification as
well asset classification could be data
within data itself there would be sub
classifications like confidential data
non
confidential data public data and so on
so forth physical assets
virtual assets networking assets
anything and everything that you can
come across
would be classified here determine and
maintain information and asset ownership
so your asset management program comes
into the picture and
when you say asset ownership the
organization owns the assets
as they are however roles and
responsibilities that you have created
in the organization will ensure
that some assets are virtually owned by
somebody that means that they are
responsible for the well-being of that
asset so you have to identify
who for example hr now hr is a function
human resources but they also need it
assets for example a payroll which will
institute
a payroll software a database right a
web application server if you will
and all of these assets are now owned by
the hr department
so there are hundreds of people in hr so
who exactly owns this
that's where we identify the owner of
that particular asset saying you are
responsible for the well-being
of these assets you belong to this
department so normally the head of that
department
would be the owner of those assets and
would determine
what kind of access controls what kind
of maintenance management
security mechanisms are required then we
talk about
protection privacy so data owners data
processors remnants
collection limitations determining
ensuring appropriate asset retention so
let's say data
right uh even if i have data how long do
i retain data if you go into
privacy acts of organizations or of
countries rather so
gdpr for european union gdpr basically
states that you
will only retain personal identifiable
information
for as long as the organization requires
it the moment you have no reason to have
that data with you
you're going to delete that data so
which means automatically says you're
going to retain that data till it makes
business
sense once you figure out it doesn't it
is not required
you are going to delete it in a secure
manner which is not recoverable
to unwanted parties so you have to
determine those asset
retention periods we have to understand
what those attention retention periods
are so even
for your physical assets there will be a
life
of the set that is associated with it
and once the life of that asset is over
even
even if the asset is working properly
you have to discard that asset and you
have to replace it you have to do this
with security in mind then the security
controls for all of these things
understanding data states data states
could be in three different aspects data
in motion
data at rest and data in use how are you
going to secure data during all these
three stages
what are the protection methods that
you're going to utilize then
in establishing information asset
handling requirements
so that's what domain 2 is all about
let's look at the questions
so the first question in domain 2 which
of the following is responsible for
setting user clearances to
computer-based
information is it operators data owners
security administrators
or data custodians understand the
question who is responsible for setting
your user clearances to computer-based
information
and the correct answer to that is
security administrators they are
responsible for setting the user
clearances
who are going to be responsible for
allowing the user clearances
that's going to be data owners what is
generally concerned with personal
security
management controls operational controls
technical controls
or human resource controls now what is
personal security personal security is
people-centric security
you're looking at people and you're
ensuring that their security comes into
the picture
technical controls can be used for data
assets
or physical assets like information
technology but technical controls may
not be
that relevant for a human a firewall is
not going to help anyone in which ways
management controls are administrative
controls that means a policy
that will help you implement controls
but for personal security is the
operational controls that are going to
be
associated with it which of the
following factors determines the
frequency of information security audits
in any given environment
so the age-old question for you to
remain secure
how often do you want to conduct a
security audit to verify
your vulnerabilities your penetration
test to verify your security controls
are working properly so would it be
dependent
upon asset value the risk based approach
management discretion
or level of realized threats and here
the answer to that question is
risk the moment a risk is identified for
example at what various stages would a
security audit be triggered
for an individual asset as well and that
can be tied down to incident management
change management and problem management
so if there is an incident
a security incident with a database
server where there has been an attack on
that server
i probably want the security audit done
on that server to identify
vulnerabilities flaws
and then to mitigate those risks
similarly if there is a change that has
been going on into your organization
you first want to go into a risk
assessment strategy and then you want to
look at security audits based on the
risk that you've identified
right so a security audit is not only
periodic based on
compliances or regulations but it also
can be
integrated really well in your incident
management problem management and change
management
scenarios that's domain number two all
right let's talk about
domain three security architecture and
engineering
now this is where you tie up security
architecture and enterprise architecture
if you look at the first domain we have
talked about risk assessments
we have talked about confidentiality
integrity and availability and then we
have moved on to the second domain where
we talked about asset
security so that's where we talked about
data data classification asset
classification
now it starts off with the enterprise
level architecture
so something like togaf what is
enterprise level architecture it's
basically
data center architect and a network
architect trying to create data flows
deciding how communications are going to
happen between various devices
they're going to try to do network
segmentation for web application servers
database servers look at network
isolations network access control
lists and may even decide how firewalls
and where firewalls would be required
once that architecture is created we
need to secure that architecture to
ensure that whatever data communications
are happening within that framework
they are secured in a manner where all
the risks
that the organization may be exposed to
are either managed mitigated accepted
transferred whichever the way it
is right so here you start off with
physical security you start up with
trusted platform modules so looking at
the outline this is where it starts off
with implement and manage engineering
processes using secure design principles
so this domain will talk about using
togaf and then using a zac man framework
to interact with all the data owners
uh all the asset owners querying them
about the
security of the assets the requirements
because it is not the security architect
who determines
how secure the device will be it is the
asset owner who determines the
requirement of security for example
continuing with the hr example that we
were talking about earlier
if the hr department of head is
responsible for the database
for the payroll application it is that
person who would be determining the
security levels
so based on the security architecture
let's say
zachman framework we would uh create a
questionnaire
that needs to be filled out by the asset
owner the hr
department of head and would be supplied
to us the security heads and then we
would try to
create a security profile based on their
requirements
so if the hr department head comes back
to me and says that they require to be
adhering to
a particular standard or they want x
kind of security
it is us who will validate that
requirement and it is us who will
execute it and protect that asset based
on their requirements
so this is where your service security
architecture meets enterprise
architecture
by using various frameworks this domain
will introduce you to not only zachman
framework it will again
take you to a trusted platform module
it will talk about itsec tc sec common
criteria
and so on so forth so this is again a
very extensive
module some people struggle with it
because it is a largely a theoretical
module
and some people would struggle with the
concept of how what is a security
architecture and an enterprise
architecture it is very important to
understand the differences between them
for example togaf is an enterprise
architecture where a data center
architect would deploy and streamline
those devices
on which a layer of security
architecture such as iso 27001
would be implemented to enhance the
security and ensure
that the infrastructure remains
protected at all point
in time this module will also deal with
managing vulnerabilities
uh on assets uh applications
web-based systems mobile systems and
embedded devices
so this is where your engineering comes
into the picture
by this module we mean when we are
deploying infrastructure we need to
engineer it with security in mind
we need to architect in such a way that
security enhances the business needs
business requirements and they are
executed in a secure manner let's look
at a few questions
based on domain three question one when
a computer uses more than one cpu in
parallel to execute instructions
it is known as multiprocessing
multitasking multi-threading
or parallel running now here we need to
understand what is the difference
between multitasking multi-threading
multi-processing and parallel running
now it would be very difficult to
explain
all these processes in in this video so
here we are talking about executing
instructions
that's multi-processing multitasking is
performing multiple tasks at the same
time
multi-threading is where processors
create their multiple threads
to manage certain functions here when we
are parallely executing instructions it
is known as multi-processor
question two who mediates all access
relationships between subjects and
objects of a system
now what is a subject what is an object
and what are access relationships
so access relationships would be your
permissions that you have created
now what are permissions permissions
would be something that a person is
authorized to do so if you look at the
cia which we discussed in the module one
confidentiality integrity and
availability how do we keep data
confidential
by only allowing authorized users access
to that data what are authorized users
authorized users are people's people who
have been identified
and are allowed access to certain
resources how do we do that by having an
identity and access management platform
in place
which will be discussed later in the
next domain but
confidentiality would include i triple a
standards i triple a starts with
identification
authentication authorization and
accountability identification is
identifying the person who they are
authentication is verifying that they
are actually who they
claim to be authorization is where the
access relationships
come into the picture where we once we
have authenticated a user we are
creating a matrix which allows them
access to certain resources to a certain
extent
some may have read-only access some may
have modify access some may have delete
access
etc so in this scenario we are talking
about access relationships between
subjects and objects of a system and who
mediates that
now when you say reference kernel
information flow model or security
kernel of firewall
in this particular scenario for this
particular question based on the options
that are available
we are talking about a rule-based access
control system which means that we have
created rules
of what is allowed into a network and
how what is
not allowed within the network this can
be controlled by using
a firewall so this can be controlled by
using a firewall question three
which of the following is not a spam
blocking architecture now
what is spam and how are you going to
block it it can be at the client side it
can be on the email server by way of
identified spam filters
could be application based in this
scenario mail
blocking services basically you creating
a blacklist which will
block emails from certain addresses or
from certain things so
this is not a spam blocking architecture
it's basically a blacklist where you're
blocking emails but spam blocking
architecture could either be at the
email server based
could be at the client side where
they're using let's say microsoft
outlook
express and they've created rules within
it or could be on an application where
you have configured rules over there
moving on to domain four now this is
where the technicalities come into the
picture communication and network
security the network security domain
covers topics focused on protecting the
network of an organization
so communications tcp channels udp
channels the tcp
so you come across the osi layer you map
the osr layer with the tcpip layer
and see how a data fragment packet
is created looking at domain four
we are talking about the osi layer open
systems interconnection uh compared to
the tcp ip or the transmission control
protocol over internet protocol models
you're talking about internet protocol
itself we're talking about converged
protocol software defined networks
wireless networks
then we're talking about securing
network components so we talk about
firewalls types of firewalls and point
security
network access control devices and we
look at them over virtualized networks
wipe multimedia looking talked about
talking about remote access data
communications
right so all of this is concerned within
domain four now
osi and tcp itself could take hours for
people to understand
to people to comprehend how computers
work now these are theoretical models
and
we need to create an understanding of
how theory
merges with the practical world let's
look at a few questions
what is the purpose of using a vpn now
the sense over here is what is a vpn or
a virtual private network how is it
created
what technologies can be utilized within
it what encryption mechanisms can be
utilized
and why are we creating that encryption
mechanism in the first place
so is it to secure remote access into a
network securely connect two networks
together
secure data tunnels within the network
or all of the above
so here with a vpn we are basically
trying to do everything
we are trying to create encrypted tunnel
between two systems
or two networks where data can be
transmitted in a secure manner
where man in the middle attacks or
network base attacks
would be mitigated a vpn can secure
packets from data link layer onwards to
the application layer
question two which of the following
characteristics are not included
in the tcp protocol now what is a tcp
protocol
tcp is a connection oriented protocol it
is a reliable protocol that is utilized
to communicate between uh servers in a
reliable manner
so a tcp protocol being a connection
oriented protocol
which is reliable in nature so which of
the following characteristics are not
included
connection less protocol that is the udp
protocols have this is not included in
the tcp protocol
question three which if you remember the
previous slide
would be the udp protocol a udp protocol
is a protocol that is used for its speed
rather than reliability
when it is real-time processing that is
required we use udp so most of our
voiped
communications would happen over udp
protocols
okay so looking at domain number five
domain five talks about identity and
access management
so this ties up with your asset
management your risk management because
if we go back to the confidentiality
integrity and availability
aspect of it identity and access
management is basically allowing
authorized users
access to resources by authenticating
them and also holding them accountable
so this becomes the sense of how you're
going to
allow people to access the resources
that you have in your organization
let's look at what this domain covers it
will talk about
physical and logical access to assets so
servers need to be protected by putting
them in a secure server room
that's just restricting access to them
and allowing access only to those few
people who require access to them
once we have secured those servers uh
this is where we talk about physical
security whereas we got a secure room
we are going to monitor that room we
will have access controls we will have
guards monitoring
who is getting access or who's trying to
get access to that environment
and then you're going to create logical
access as well where we
let's say have swipe cards on the door
locks so anyone with
logical swipe card can access that
particular facility
you're also looking at managing
identification and authentication of
people devices and services
so here we are going to talk about
authentication mechanisms
single authentication multi-factor
authentication we are talking about
single sign-ons we will talk about
federated identity management modules
we'll look at casb or cloud access
service brokers
we'll talk about session management from
applications
and so on so forth we will also talk
about third party identity as a service
provider
where we integrate those identities like
open id into our organization
and we validate people based on the
identity that they have created with
those
organizations then we talk about access
control list
which would be role based access
controls mandatory access controls
discretionary access controls
attribute base access controls
rule-based access controls
and then there are a lot of theoretical
models that are integrated
in this module which talk about
lattice-based approach
which we'll talk about other theoretical
models which will help you
align how identity and access management
is implemented in an organization
so at this point in time we will also be
looking at a life cycle of how
identities are managed
for example onboarding of people
deboling of people
termination of employees employees as
they move
within the organization by getting
promotions demotions
or changing departments and assuming a
new role
so here we talk about how we can
provision an identity how we can
de-provision an identity
how it is to be managed we are going to
create a
relationship between the creator of this
identity
and the approver who is going to be a
manager so even if somebody is allowed
to create an identity they will only
create it
if they have an approval from
appropriate manager so let's look at
questions from domain number five
the first one which of the following is
the most important factor while
selecting a biometric system for
securing
critical assets now here the domain
talks about the types of authentication
mechanisms
there are five types essentially three
basic types
which talk about something that you know
which is a password
something that you have a swipe card
someone that
you are a biometric somewhere that you
are
location based and something that you do
like capture
so these are the five basic
authentication types or mechanisms
that you can utilize in an organization
multifactor authentication
is having multiple of these options
in integrated in our identity and access
management module to enhance the
security
now coming back to biometrics biometrics
have positives and negatives
amongst them so uh with the biometric
there are two types that we talk about
false race of earth
false acceptance rate and false
rejection rate what is a false
acceptance rate
uh somebody let's say you're using a
thumb print to authenticate people
somebody put down their thumb print the
person is not actually authorized
however it was read incorrectly and the
door got unlocked and the person got
access to that particular
area which is a false acceptance rate a
false rejection rate is an author
authenticated or
authorized person actually trying their
thumbprint but
it not getting recognized does they did
not get access to the area
or to the device that they wanted now
the question here is
which of the following is the most
important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets
now would i want to focus on false
rejection rate or false acceptance rate
then we also have equal error rate
and maximum allowable downtime maximum
allowable downtime is if the biometric
measure fails
and if nobody's getting access to any of
the resources to what level or to what
extent
would my business be able to tolerate
such an outage here the
correct answer is the false acceptance
rate because
if an unauthorized person gets access to
my devices
that's the worst case scenario if the
biometric system is down
and nobody's getting access that may
still be acceptable rather than having
an unauthorized person getting access
to very sensitive data false rejection
rate is also
detrimental to the organization however
it is not as bad
as having a false acceptance rate
introduced in the organization
the second question which are the two
major factors to measure biometric
performance again
the question from the previous one far
false acceptance rate
and fr false rejection rate or fse and
er
ier and far fr and gic they
don't actually relate so the correct
answer here is far
false acceptance rate and false
rejection rate so these are the two
major factors
false rejection rate may still be a
little bit acceptable
but a false acceptance rate is not
tolerable at all
next question a commercial application
for steganography that is used to
identify documents
or verify their authenticity is either a
digital checksum
an md5 hash a digital signature or a
watermark
now here the keywords matter you're
talking about steganography so suddenly
people start thinking about hiding data
within data
and then if you just isolate the words
identified documents or verify their
authenticity we
would basically directly go to a digital
signature because that's what we
utilized for non-repudiation however
what the question refers to
is an application for steganography
seconography
is hiding some element which would be
visible only to known people
we can utilize technography on for to
benefit our
ourselves or our organization by using
it to identify the authenticity of a
document so if i
i'm going to print out a document maybe
a watermark on the document which is not
visible to the naked eye
but when i want to validate the document
i would search for
that particular watermark and that is
the correct answer for this particular
question
so that's what domain five is all about
all right let's look at domain number
six
which is security assessment and testing
now this domain
is all about assessments auditing
strategies
and testing so uh from this domain what
you're going to take away
is talking about internal audits
external audits third party audits
uh in the security control testing uh
strategizing about
how we implement a vulnerability
management system
a program within the organization that
is repeatable consistent
and measurable can be tied up with other
management programs like patch
management incident management and
anything and everything
that requires a vulnerability assessment
like even change management if something
is going to change in an organization
you can have a vulnerability assessment
done before you want to even think about
allowing it or disallowing that change
similarly
with penetration testing to validate the
vulnerabilities that you've identified
uh log reviews having a siem tool that
will help you analyze
or create a patent analysis of what's
happening within the infrastructure
what's happening within the organization
from a security perspective
then you're talking about collecting
security process data
account management when we say account
management identity and
access management life cycle so
onboarding of an employee
of voting of an employee the lateral
movements of an employee in an
organization
when they're getting promoted or they
are transferred in from one department
to another
right so all of these would come under
security assessment and testing to see
how those policies
are functioning to analyze the
effectiveness of those policies
does the requirement for conducting
vulnerability assessment and penetration
tests
so let's look at a few questions on this
domain
and let's start off with the first one
which of the following ways requires the
involvement of an information security
analyst
so out of these four options assistance
requirements definition
system design program development or
program testing
during which phase would you involve a
security analyst
now for this we first need to identify
why we require a security analyst
what is the job requirement what is the
activity that is going to be conducted
by a security analyst
right so in this scenario the correct
answer is program testing
in the dev program development phase uh
we won't need an analyst
we would need a program manager and
architects
who can develop a particular program who
can
give it some semblance of what needs to
be achieved in the system design it
would be again an architect
who's going to develop that system in
the systems requirements definition
again
so in the systems requirements
definition it's a requirement gathering
about what is
what you need to adhere to what is going
to be
the baseline that you're going to create
so from these four options you need to
identify
where would you place a security analyst
right in the exam
it's the most probable answer that
you're looking for it's not the most
idealistic answer right so from these
four options
security analysts would most likely be
involved in the program testing phase
rather than any other phase the second
question which of the following
techniques is generally not used for
monitoring purposes
now when you say monitoring what is
monitoring monitoring
is looking into logs activities uh
anything and everything that has already
happened
so you are reacting to something that
has already happened and which of these
following techniques is not used for
monitoring so
you're collecting logs you're analyzing
those logs
what would be not be utilized a
penetration test
intrusion detection violation processing
or counter measures testing
right now when you're monitoring you
would monitor a penetration test to
analyze
if the test was successful or not
intrusion detection
that's the first input that you look at
for analysis
violation processing anything is
violated any processes
any policies you analyze them and you
uh you monitor them does you come to
know that this has happened in counter
measures testing
there's basically a test of the
effectiveness of the countermeasures
that are already implemented
at that point in time you may not be
monitoring these the software program
that
acts on behalf of user in their absence
to carry out operations is known as an
agent worm applet or a browser so a
program that acts on behalf of a user
in their absence to carry out operations
is either an agent an appellate or a
worm or a browser
a browser is nothing but a software that
allows you to surf the internet a worm
is a malicious application that would
be more of a nuisance value than
anything else an appellate is a
something that allows you
interconnectivity an agent is something
that will
that can be automated used for automated
tasks
and can run those tasks in the absence
of a particular user
so if you look at these questions
understanding what each and every word
means understanding and highlighting the
keywords in the question itself
and then analyzing the scenario that you
are placed in and then identifying the
most appropriate answer
for that particular question that is how
you want to approach a cissp exam
looking at the next domain domain number
seven
and that's security operations let's
look at what security operations has
for us now in security operations you're
looking like looking at a sock a
security operation center
so your regular volunteer management
incident management
problem management change management
placing controls
analyzing all that information so
probably having an siem tool
configuring this iem tool collecting all
those data so identifying event sources
what are event sources
when i have an siem implemented i am not
going to expect this iem to
automatically
start collecting data all by itself and
then again i
don't expect the siem tool to understand
what kind of data it needs to collect so
for me in a security operation center
after i've installed an siem tool
i first need to configure it to identify
which devices i want to monitor
from which devices i want to collect
that information
and where do i want to store it once i
have all that information in place
after that i'm going to analyze that
data to identify if anything has been
incorrectly going on or is there any
security incident that has happened and
those would be raised and incidences
and that would be sent to the sock team
for analysis and then an incident
response
right similarly intrusion detection and
prevention
logs would be utilized to identify
something that may have
been missed by the ids ips itself you're
going to place
controls for investigations like
administrative
uh controls which would be policies that
you have made then you've got criminal
laws or some
uh if something bad has happened that
can be described as a crime
based on the law of that land how you're
going to deal with it civil laws regular
regulatory laws and industry standards
regulatory laws would be
for example gdpr in the european union
right
a civil law would be where there is no
criminal
activity that has happened but let's say
there's a breach of contract
between two organizations and the civil
lawsuit has been filed against our
organization
for a breach of service level agreements
regulatory would be the gdpr act where
you have to
report to a regulatory body and if there
are any flaws you could be fined
industry standards iso 27001 pci dss and
so on so forth so
when you're looking at these
requirements for investigation
all of these would have prescribed how
you're going to handle that
investigation
if it is a criminal investigation an
organization by itself doesn't have the
right to investigate they have to go to
a law enforcement agency and there is a
procedure to follow
in case of a civil lawsuit there are
lawyers who would deal with this
this kind of activity send out notices
to the other party
then go to a court of law to file a
lawsuit over there
in gdpr there are timelines on how
you're going to report a breach or how
you're going to report an incident and
so on so forth
so in the security operations you're
creating a security operation center
in alignment with all of these five
requirements
you're going to look at logging and
monitoring activities having that
siem tool which will identify those
devices that you want to monitor collect
relevant information
that is prescribed based on all those
five
investigation types that we just
discussed then you're looking at
when you're looking at identification of
assets you go back to your asset
inventory asset register
you look at all the assets that you have
and then you make your strategy and plan
how you want to collect those logs right
and then
this module will deal about how do you
want to handle identity and access
management privilege account management
service level agreements and so on so
forth
so this basically is the day-to-day
day-to-day business activity of an
organization from a security perspective
so you are there to identify incidents
as a cis you won't be executing this but
you
would be creating policies revolving
all of these aspects so yeah this is
what you need to consider
this is what you need to strategize upon
and this is what you want to advise the
organization
to what needs to be in place to be more
effective from a security perspective
let's look at the few questions from uh
this domain
how does a subject get access to an
object in a multi-level security policy
now
first we need to understand what a
multi-level security policy is
we need to understand what a subject is
and what an object is
let's look at the options first the
subject sensitivity label must dominate
the object sensitivity label
the subject sensitivity label
subordinates the object sensitivity
sensitivity label the subject
sensitivity label is subordinated by the
object sensitivity label
and to repeat the sensitivity tags again
and again the subject sensitivity label
is dominated by the object sensitivity
label too much sensitivity in a single
slide however you can see that this just
confuses the person
of what they're trying to read and not
only you missing what keywords
are so people normally focus on a
keyword called multi-level security
policy and start getting confused in
that
well while we do disregard what a
subject and an object
is right so a subject and an object is a
relationship that is created between
identity and access management subject
being the user
object being the resource that needs to
be accessed by that particular user
after which comes a multi-level security
policy which is basically the access
control matrix that you have created
between these multiple objects and
multiple subjects
so for example in this domain you would
also talk about
theoretical models for access management
including lattice based approached where
the sensitivity labels come into the
picture
you would talk about clark wilson model
you will talk about
bella padula model and a few other
models
right all of them theoretical in nature
which can then
based on other implementations be
implemented in a real-time scenario
so all that understanding comes into the
picture and then you need to identify
how those sensitivity labels
in a lattice-based approach could allow
you to create
those labels for your subjects and
objects and then the identity and access
management tool
would become the verification factor
where it identifies the labels
for the subject and the object and based
on those labels
they allow or disallow connectivity or
allow
connections to happen now here the
correct answer is that
the subject sensitivity label must
dominate the object's
sensitivity label so the user should
have a sensitivity label
that allows them access to the object
which has an equivalent sensitivity
label
so understanding those models becomes
very much important
not only from an exam's perspective but
when you're creating a policy
you basically are going to use these
terminologies and you're going to
create a policy around this moving on
second question managers of which
department are ideal for the development
of information security policy for an
organization
business operation information
technology purchase or human resources
now managers of which department are
ideal for development of information
security policy for an organization
and when we say information security
policy we would obviously assume that is
the i.t department who's going to deal
with it
and it's the information technology in
this r in this case
but that's incorrect it is the business
operation
why because right from the first domain
so we would be taught
in the training for cissp that security
needs to
enhance the business functionality not
the other way around
so we are in the business or if we are
in the function of conducting a business
which would offer services and those
services that are being offered the
business activity that has been
conducted
should be supplemented by security so
those business activities could be
conducted in a secure manner
at no point in time is going is security
going to be a deterrent to business
the only reason for us anything to
become a deterrent to business is the
legality of it
if a business is illegal it will not
happen or it should not happen
however if the business activity is
legal then security should not stop that
activity from happening
security should be implemented in such a
way that it is the business activity
strengthened
there is security embedded within it
secure by design
and then the business activity goes on
so even if you're a
chief information security officer or a
security manager and you go and talk
with the
the board of directors or the steering
committee as the terms
you will come across in this training uh
you will understand that it is
it's these people who would define how
the business is going to work what kind
of business activity you're going to do
and then you provide the example and
i'll give you an example here
let's say i'm an online retailer and i
want to sell good
goods online which is legal i'm selling
all legal goods
goods now i want security to the
team to come in and they would help me
to secure the the function of being an
online
e-tailer if you will my security team is
not going to come and tell me of not to
do
go into that business or stop some
services because they may be insecure
right the security team's requirement is
that if i want to sell goods online
they need to now create an architecture
of devices
of clouds of whatever is required to
make it secure
so thus the managers of business
operations will always
be the ideal department for the
development of information security
policies they decide what is what the
business is going to happen
and then the security team just
complements it by adding the security to
it for example
just going on with this a website is
launched with http the security team
comes into the picture and says data in
motion needs security so we're going to
convert it into https
and at no point in time are they going
to say http is vulnerable so we are not
going to do this
we rather become a wholesale shop or
something like that and i'm just giving
an example
and rather than me just rambling on
let's move on to the next question
question three installing malicious
software on the system to allow future
backdoor access leads to violation
of what integrity does it violate the
data integrity
system user or network now malicious
software
on a system to allow future backdoor
access
so what are we doing here we are
basically installing a software or an
application
on a particular system which allows a
hacker a backdoor access
to the system so this would violate the
integrity
of the system itself right the data
would be compromised
but the data would be compromised
because the system got compromised
a user doesn't matter because a backdoor
is a backdoor entry where
you can get access without even logging
in as a user
and a network is just a way of
communication at this point in time
but the sense being that system got
infected and through that infection
you got access to whatever was on that
particular system now
that's domain number seven domain number
eight which is the last domain
in the cissp exam is software
development
security sdlc or ssdlc secure software
development
lifecycle right that's what is discussed
in this domain
let's go back to the cissp guide and see
what this domain would
consist of so software development
security and you can see software
development life cycles coming in
so they're going to talk about different
life cycles like waterfall model
they're going to talk about agile
they're going to talk about modified
waterfall
this module also will talk about uh
devsecops devops
and anything and everything that would
be there with the software development
lifecycle now
when we say software development
lifecycle the essence of assist
is to add another s to the sdlc
the sdlc stands for software development
lifecycle the sys adds one more as the
secure software development life cycle
so as with everything secure by design
which means security needs to be
integrated at every phase
of the life cycle and not should it
should not be bolted on
for example a waterfall model talks
about how the software
is going to be developed and how it is
going to be published
or released at the end of the life cycle
at no point in time does it talk about
security
does security archery at that point will
die at that point in time would come
into the picture and decide
what are the requirements of the
software what uh what are the security
vulnerabilities or the risk that they
see
so threat modeling would happen and all
those things need to be introduced right
from the inception so if there are
developers or if there is a business
requirement for an application let's go
back to the previous example
i am an e-tailer so to become an
e-tailer not do i
only need a website i will need a web
application for that function it will be
given out
so i need to develop that application in
a regular lifecycle model
i developed that application and then go
into security where i do a vapt on that
application find out that
there are disastrous results and then i
go back and start coding again
which is not a good scenario so i have
hired a cis
who will then come into the picture
during the sdnc and
the inception itself when businessmen
are talking about
uh how the business is going to happen
at that point in time the cis
will come in and start with a threat
modeling exercise saying
you know what let's talk about what are
the risks this application is going to
face
you're going to handle a lot of payment
information because
people need to pay for the products
right so credit cards you're going to be
uh going to be involved there's a
database or
sql injection attacks so these are the
threads that we're looking at
and now a threat modeling exercise would
be followed by a risk assessment
then would be looked at upon a by an
impact analysis
and then based on that you will
prioritize those risks you will then
educate your developers to use secure
coding practices
at the same time security testing would
be done to see how the
application is being evolved and then by
the time that the software development
lifecycle comes to an
end you would have a secure software
which
had security by design integrated since
the inception
rather than having bolted on now this is
the ideal scenario that you're looking
for
the expense and the budgeting that's
where the
balance of layer of
capital uh investments and
uh time to market and all that commerce
comes into the picture but for the
training
we will always be in an ideal scenario
we'll always have enough time
enough resources monetary and human and
the exam basically looks at a very ideal
scenario
in which you got just about everything
you just need to make the correct
decision
at no point in time are you going to
think that if i start doing
a particular strategy it is going to
cost me a lot of money so i don't want
to do that that's the real whole
scenario
in the real world you look at the costs
you look at the timelines deadlines and
then you take
a informed decision of how much you want
to invest in what
in the ideal world for the cispe exam or
the cissp
exam there are no limitations you
are looking at the most correct way of
doing those things
and thus you are you identify those
requirements
and that's how you answer the exam so
you're looking at the security software
environments that you require
configuration management
auditing and logging of changes security
impact of acquired software now
in this scenario we talked about
developing a software what if i purchase
a third-party software
and i introduce it into my organization
now this software when integrated
how is it going to impact my current
security controls
impact my current identity access
management my networking my
other applications my communications so
that's something that you want to assess
as well right so let's
go for the questions question one in
which of the following read level the
drive array continues to operate even if
any disks fails
now in the actual exam they're not going
to be very technical
it's a managerial exam so they may not
ask you these kind of questions but the
knowledge is still required so you need
to know that there is something called
raid
the different levels of raid because you
might want to
use that as a solution in a particular
thing how do you want to implement rate
and all of those that's not
the knowledge that we want but in this
scenario rate level seven
is the ideal answer question two which
of the following
steps can be utilized or can be used to
protect an organization against the
failure of a critical software
firm now basically what does this talk
about
this talks about disaster recovery or
this this talks about business
continuity
for example there's a failure of some
sort
when there is something that fails what
does it do it interrupts the business
so the moment of business interruption
happens what should kick in
the business continuity plan if the
business continuity plan fails
that the disaster recovery plan kicks in
so if you look into it
as we go in we might even come against
uh
terminologies like rtos rpos return time
objective
and recovery point objective and at that
point in time you want to look at
how do we want to recover from a data
loss and thus
you will come across solutions now of
the four options full backups
differential backups and incremental
backups
and the fourth one software escrow
agreement what is the difference
between these the full backup is a
complete backup
of the entire data that you have taken
now
it sounds easy but in an organization
data could be terabytes petabytes
and to do a complete backup might take
days weeks or a lot of time
right it's not just copying one megabyte
from a
hard disk to a usb drive and be done
with the backup
so full backups may be possible but not
on a regular basis so maybe
you do a full backup every week which
means that at the end of the week if the
data loss happens
then you have lost the data for an
entire week because the
backup was last week thus it's not a
very good solution and
to complement that we could use
incremental backups and differential
backups
right so the training would include all
of these definitions of what these
backups are what
happens and then the fourth option
software escrow agreement what
is that now in a software development or
a software lifecycle if i've purchased a
software from a third party
my biggest risk is not of me getting
hacked on the app
the software getting hacked from a
business continuity the biggest risk
is if the software provider goes
bankrupt or is taken over by somebody
else
or stop supporting the software then
what what am i to do because
i may have invested millions of dollars
or
reinvesting into a different product and
migrating to a different product would
be expensive
very costly and need to be very time
consuming so what do i do at that point
in time
so there is an option for software
escrow agreement what does that mean
that the source code of that software is
placed
in an escrow which means let's say in a
bank
where the bank will hold the soft the
source code in a secure manner
and the source code cannot be accessed
or by be modified
either by the developing organization or
the purchasing organization
so it just sits with the bank if the
developers go out of business or they
stop supporting
at that point in time the escrow can be
opened
and the purchaser that that's us in this
case can still get the source code
so now we can develop the software or we
can go into the source code analyze
and save ourselves from a disaster right
so these are the four
options now here you're talking about a
critical software firm that failed
you're not talking about data that
failed so the correct answer here
is the software escrow agreement right
question number three
now here we come across the word
development model which one of these
is a meta model that incorporates
several other software development
models
are we looking at waterfall modified
waterfall
spiral or critical patch here the
correct answer is a waterfall model
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on cssp
training i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions related to the
topics that were covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here